[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm linked and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we're gonna do the Q&A
that we said that we didn't know if we
wanted to do that's right the last
year's series all along the way we
prompted you guys to use hashtag ear
biscuits and let us know how you were
processing and if particular questions
arose let us know and I think I don't
think we said if concerns arose let us
know but I guess that happened - yeah
well we what we talked about last week
was how we're processing this whole
thing and how we have a tendency I think
maybe it may be me more than link I have
a tendency to once I start looking at
questions and thinking about what people
are saying and asking like I start
wanting to defend myself and to justify
myself especially if I see that I'm kind
of being misunderstood or misrepresented
but I am becoming a healthier person as
I get older and I am learning more what
is just me and my ego and so we decided
to instead of getting into answering
questions last week to kind of just get
into our process but also with you know
what we talked about was we don't want
this podcast to become a place where we
just kind of spout off our opinions when
it comes to things that were ultimately
not qualified to talk about and so
because you can very quickly get into
this place where two guys who are basic
basically have been making a living on
YouTube for over a decade are sitting
around and trying to tell you their
particular apologetic giving persuasive
arguments for what for what beliefs you
should adopt not something that we're
gonna do because there's a lot of people
out there who have dedicated their lives
to studying some of the things that we
talked about and they're experts in
their field and there's so many books
that have been written
articles that have been written about
all the things that we talked about so
it is up to you to go and do your own
research come to your own conclusions
but I do think that there were a lot of
questions that were asked just from a
very curious place like we told long
stories about our stories and our faith
journeys and we condense them down into
less than two hours we left a lot of
details out we left a lot of people
wondering about different parts of the
process wondering about how we think
about particular things now and I've
seen a lot of questions kind of grouped
together mm-hmm so I thought and also I
think these questions have also been
coming from the Christians that we stay
in contact with in our own lives which
is one question that we got you guys are
you guys still friends with yes we're
still friends with lots of Christians
and we've got really close lifelong
friends who are still you know
presidents of seminaries and and Old
Testament professors and you know
pastors and so we've got a lot of people
who can challenge a lot of the things
that we said and we're in conversation
so but I think a lot of those questions
come from a curious place and so we want
to honor your questions honor your
curiosity and just kind of give our
personal perspective this isn't designed
to be like this is what you should think
this isn't prescriptive this is just to
kind of fill in the gap of your
curiosity if you if you have it yeah so
you you've you've grouped together some
questions which you're going to tee up I
kind of know some of these but not all
of them but yeah for me you know our
stories are so different that they
engendered a different flavor of
response and when there's when you're
talking about when your story talks so
much about the issues in that it did
that it invites people to engage on this
apologetics level on this reasons for
believing certain things level whereas
you know I'm not getting as much as that
as though
I'm well I think I'm I think I'm I think
I'm grateful because I didn't want you
well I decidedly shouldn't feel bad you
seem like you you seem like you almost
felt bad about not getting uh I told my
story in the way that I told it
piggybacking off of your story because
it drives it would drive me nuts to have
the responses that are directly
addressed to your story like well it
would just it would that was not a
healthy environment and so I'm glad that
the way that I told my story even though
a lot of what you experience again I was
there for it and we discussed it and I
was the sounding board and I didn't shut
any of that down yeah when I stand by
what I said when you told your story
which is I think that your story is
ultimately more relatable to more people
than mine is but people who think maybe
we'll come back to what what the
difference is in response and the
magnitude of response like what that
means all I'll say right now is that
people who think like me
are also behaved like me which is they
talk more about this particular type
thing
they make youtube they make podcasts and
YouTube channel they set up events where
they debate about it right and so that
ain't me yeah and that's how I am yeah
if I was still in the faith I would be
right there alongside them so if I was
like that we'd have a totally different
podcast
yeah totally different online persona I
guess that at this point but so I will
say before you get into those questions
that is I a lot of the main thing that
people responded to my story was like
the stories that I told him particularly
this story about like you leaving me on
the side of the road so if you're more
interested in the story aspect of things
once we get through some of these other
questions we can come back to that
because people are interested in your
point of view because I didn't say
anything
right and I will say if I mean now we're
six and a half minutes in but if you
judge if you happen to be someone who's
just checking out your biscuits for the
first time
and you got at this point and you're not
overly good this is something yeah we
did a whole series first of all this
podcast is just two buddies you've known
each other forever just trying to figure
out life together being friends and
talking about the process and things
that were interested in and one of the
things that we decided to do over a
month ago is to kind of tell our full
stories of our evangelical Christian
backgrounds how that got us to where
we're at in our careers you played an
integral role and what we call the lost
years when we call it in the lost years
because they were literally never talked
about until we talked about him on the
podcast I find it hard to believe this
is the first episode anyone's listened
to but somebody might be and you know
what those were long episodes just skip
them and then we were free to listen so
we told our individual deconstruction
stories and and we asked you to
participate and asking some questions
and now we're gonna finally well we did
another podcast we talked about how we
didn't feel how we didn't know what we
were going to do by answering questions
but now we're gonna answer some
questions okay one of the things again
I'm not gonna credit anybody it may
become some of these later questions but
again this is me this was a group so
these are all from Lincoln okay yeah
these are from multiple people so you
asked yourself what if I'm wrong I said
that during my story there was a point
in which when I was a Christian and I
hadn't experienced a bunch of doubts I
said what if I'm wrong do you ask
yourself that question now what if
you're wrong now that's that question
because it seems like I mean our our
belief on the inside it was was like it
was like a hedging your bets Occam's
razor kind of what if you're wrong it's
like worst case you know I'm worst case
on the outside you're risking eternal
punishment separation from God right I
think you talked about Pascal's wager
Pascal's wager Occam's razor I can raise
asking Occam's razor I can't even say it
now
get the the simplest solution solution
the Pascal's wager is essentially right
place Pascal famous mathematician and
thinker from a long time ago who was a
Christian basically said what do I have
to lose by living a Christian life you
know because I get to you have a lot to
gain you have a lot to gain life by by
going to the dark side which I'm going
to talk a little bit about Hell in a
second
related to Pascal's wager and why I
don't find it compelling but yeah but
the question what if you're wrong what
about Occam's razor those razor I shave
with it every day
that's why should I show you underneath
my beard with Occam's razor
well what's your response yes I asked
myself if I'm wrong yeah III hope I
never stop doing it like I like I said
at the end of the podcast Mona I told my
story it's like if anything I have
demonstrated a willingness to change my
mind right to sort of extricate myself
from something that is still very much a
part of the way I think in the way that
I behave was my entire worldview in my
entire orienting principle in life and I
moved away from it in spite of wanting
to not want to I didn't want to stop
believing it and so yeah I continued to
ask myself that question I hope I hope I
never stopped asking myself the question
what if I'm wrong I will say that though
it's the flavor of the question has
changed a little bit because I no longer
have real definitive ideas about things
that I find hard to be definitive about
like I don't know what I think about the
afterlife I don't I have some guesses
but I don't have any convictions about
the afterlife I don't have any
convictions about the supernatural
reality of the world and so therefore
what when I had certainty about those
things and I knew that I was gonna go to
heaven and that people who all Tamara
sugreev with me were going to go to hell
what if I'm wrong felt different
absolutely I feel I feel now like I
don't have to be right
I felt like I had to be right before and
I you know if I was if I didn't feel
confident about a certain aspect of my
rightness I had to bolster that I had to
read a little something about it you
know I think that it was if if he had a
doubt about the resurrection of Jesus
then you would google evidence for the
resurrection and it will come in droves
and what I don't you know it took a long
time for me to get to a point where I'm
like I'm actually going to Google
evidence against the resurrection just
just to check it out you know but I
guess since the shoes on the other foot
I should ask us well now are we Google
in things like evidence for the
resurrection and I think that's a later
question you have so we let's come back
to keep going this is this is this is
almost fun a related question that kind
of comes on the heels of what if you're
wrong is what about Hell do you not live
in fear that what like if you if you
were right if in the first you know
three quarters of your life you were
right then this version of you who is
wrong is going to hell
and not only are you going to hell but
you're leading your family you're your
best friend and anyone who's listening
to your podcast potentially your live
bands your you're leading that about
what about the impression of a fan and
and and okay so the first part of the
question is personal are you scared of
Hell okay oh you're scared of Hell my
answer to this is that when I was a
Christian I was not scared of all the
other potential outcomes as presented by
all the other religions right so
according to some conservative flavors
of Islam I would have been considered an
infidel and probably wouldn't have
gotten into paradise there is the Muslim
concept of hell's a little bit different
and how you how you qualify for
but whatever there are some people who
believe a certain thing in that faith
who would have said that I was going to
hell there was some people there's some
people who believe in reincarnation and
might believe that based on my actions I
was going to come back a grasshopper
whatever the particular and now I'm not
trying to make light of that I'm just
saying that that could be somebody's
idea I didn't lose any sleep about those
potential outcomes when I was a
Christian because as a Christian I had a
very long list of people's beliefs about
the afterlife that I was that I didn't
believe I wasn't scared of their hell
because I didn't believe in it there's a
very long list if you really tried to
make it right so the only thing I've
done is I've added the Christian hell to
that list of things that I don't believe
in and so it becomes you know it's not
as easy as a mental exercises I just
made it seem because when you believe in
it for so long and that's what you
thought when you were in your formative
years your adolescent years it's a
little bit more difficult to disregard
but I would say that sort of the the
short answer is I don't lose any sleep
about it for the same reason that you as
a Christian don't lose sleep about going
to someone else's hell and I didn't lose
sleep about Hell when I believed I had
escaped it and I I think it was just
something that I did not like to think
about like I mean you might think that
with all that with the experience that I
described and like the guilt and the
pressure that I placed on myself within
that system you might think that there
was a direct connection to Hell like
there's a lot of people who with a
similar makeup as me would then take the
next step to like well I got him am I
really saved I got him I gotta make sure
I'm saved every day like I got up I
gotta pray that sinner's prayer but
Jesse was told my wife Jesse who went to
a very conservative Christian private
school was told when she was a kid
and of course she struggles with
scrupulous 'ti the scrupulous a version
of OCD so this is especially
troublesome for her they say which is
the religiously applied version of OCD
yeah if you're 99% sure that you're
saved you're a hundred percent lost
didn't you tell him you tell children
that they had to be assured of their
salvation so I wasn't told that and you
were there all along so we weren't told
that no notice I wasn't you know I I
never interacted with hell that way it
wasn't something I was constantly faced
with it wasn't like it was constantly
talked about what we're actually talking
about it a lot and it might give the
false impression that it was shoved down
our throats constantly but what's not a
pleasant thing to think about yes so but
instead we just didn't think about it
and then because it's not pleasant and
the more you think about it I think it
it gets less pleasant if not for you for
the people on the outside yeah and so
it's not it's a place I never wanted to
go I wanted to go to one of those I
never would I never went to one of these
and where they scale the hell out of you
like a Christian haunted house yeah just
like a Hell House never did Allah ween
you would have unfortunately I would
have come out giddy a part of a
denomination that did that kinda you
wouldn't come out satanic we just did a
Fall Festival because we didn't believe
in Halloween but we didn't do Hell
houses and I feel like it was a missed
opportunity but this is also the reason
why I don't find Pascal's wager the same
I apply the same logic to my response to
Pascal's wager as I do to this and that
is you can take Pascal's wager and you
can use that to argue for any faith you
know what I'm saying it's like because
it you they present it as such a value
prop any faith it presents a value
proposition that ain't a consequence for
not following it so then if you don't
you can't forget about that value that's
like well if I don't I I have so much to
gain here it's not just what you have to
lose well what I'm saying is that you
from a Muslim perspective you could also
have Pascal's wager and you could argue
that against a Christian you can take
and you can start with
particular religious perspective and say
this is what you have to gain and this
is what you have to lose and then you
can argue from that standpoint so it
doesn't actually it's just not it's only
compelling to someone who's trying to
hold on to Christian belief but it's not
very compelling to someone who doesn't
have Christian belief
give me sense and isn't yes isn't there
also a factor in that that's like you're
you're not just mentally a assenting to
certain beliefs but you have to have
like a heart connection right what don't
you get you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make it work what kind of
relationship with God is that that it's
just based on a fear of Hell or but well
maybe I'm gonna stay I'm gonna stick
around just in case you guys are right
like that doesn't feel like a vibrant
relationship with God it just kind of
feels like a mental exercise the second
half of this this question or questions
that you've grouped together when you
talk about Hell is what you what about
speaking out what if speaking out has
led other people into eternal punishment
but if you're wrong about this right
wasn't that in the second half of the
question
the you added that but I have I have
seen that like what about the fans and
the friends isn't that the question you
have an answer I've seen that one I felt
like we answered it at the towards the
end of last week i mean when i when i
read the exchange between two mythical
beasts and it was hey we're just we're
presenting our perspective but everyone
has to make their own decision
I just feel like our audience is can't
understand that and I think even if I
know that a lot of people were shaken up
but again I don't think it troubles me
that I just I just feel like in I get
nervous when I make generalizations
about the church but I do feel like it's
a little they err on the side of like
okay let's not fully engage in our
doubts let's not have it's you know it
just didn't feel like something that you
could talk about freely it was like
let's have I gotta have a special
meeting with my pastor and I don't know
how I'm gonna bring this up and I don't
know how he's gonna respond it's like
because this it feels like there's so
much at stake it's not there's not this
open dialogue where it's like you really
can it's gonna be normal to have doubts
and to engage in that I just don't feel
like that was the environment but I feel
like that's the environment that I try
to create with my kids it's like listen
don't think that your daddy knows
everything you know yeah and like you
said before it's more about they learn
so much more from our actions and they
do from what we say that I think that
they know that I don't know everything
but at least I'm you know I try to be
sorry that just as one example I try to
seek forgiveness from them things like
that so what's my point I think if I'm
gonna if I'm gonna open up my kids to
that level of honest dialogue with
wherever they're at I'm comfortable
doing that with our audience and and
them being able to make decisions
responsible decisions for themselves and
not just take what we believe hook line
and sinker for themselves yeah so I just
cannot I cannot put that burden on my
back and I'm not gonna do it okay I
don't disagree with anything you just
said but playing devil's advocate if I
were still a Christian who believed that
you know Christianity holds the ultimate
truth to man's salvation then I would
believe that distorting that truth or
misleading people would be a horrible
thing to do and true everyone needs to
make their own decision but you also
have a huge platform and you've got
impressionable kids listening to you and
you're shaking up their situation what
if you're wrong I don't so I don't
disagree with what you're saying they
need to make their own decision but you
have influence when you speak again
there but that my issue with this
particular question well I hope that was
my influence was that it opened quite a
desk and you haven't you're not wrong
but I'm saying the reason that even what
I
said playing devil's advocate is not
compelling to me is the same reason that
Pascal's wager is not compelling to me
or the same reason that I don't fear
hell and that is because I don't you
know the hell that you're saying that I
might be sending people to I don't
believe in that hell you believe in that
hell and so I don't think that that's
what I'm doing of course if I thought
that that's what I was doing or if I
thought that there was a reasonable
chance that that's what I was doing I
wouldn't do it right but I don't believe
that so I actually think that by getting
people to act and ask those questions
and to kind of explore the foundations
of their faith I think that ultimately
just as a species questioning that and
getting closer to the truth is going to
ultimately serve everyone's best
interest
I'm not because I'm not suggesting
something that you should replace your
faith with I'm figuring all that out in
my own life but I'm just saying that hey
if this isn't this isn't gonna take us
to the next phase in our human evolution
then we got to figure out what is and we
don't need to try to bring along some we
don't need to try to bring along
something that's actually not gonna
service our species that's the more
question we've got some more questions
but we are gonna take a short break
and what are we trying to get people
interested in right now mythical calm
has interest galore Rhett don't
undersell it just because I'm not
wearing something doesn't mean that
mythical calm is not a burgeoning center
well it was all just a setup for you
link because of mythicality what I want
to say ASSA tea and tomfoolery on your
body when you look at this white t-shirt
that I'm wearing and you say to yourself
man think of all the things that that
white t-shirt could be this is like a
canvas that I'm planning this thought in
your head of this white t-shirt that
could be anything you could say mythical
on it okay have a nice picture of I
don't know look at myself so I don't
know what to commit to at this point to
my shirt I've had this shirt we don't
sell anything like I've had this shirt
for probably 15 years how to kill him
- I was wearing this shirt yeah that was
a long freaking time ago yeah it's like
a cowboy style you know I still like it
at a certain point you might realize
that you've been wearing the same
clothes for a long time mythical comma
can happen at rep your boys let's get
back into some questions hit it okay now
again you haven't suffered from this as
much as I have and I'm using the term
suffered loosely but because my story
was very much my intellectual journey
and I questioned some foundational
things about the Christian faith of
course people who know and care about
these things have suggested many many
many many resources for me to check out
and I want to talk about I want to hear
a book report
lissa how do I want to get into this
because people have suggested websites
articles YouTube videos books and all by
people who are probably definitely many
of them but probably most of them are
smarter than me definitely most of them
are more well studied than me they
haven't been making youtube videos
almost exclusively for a decade they've
you know they've been studying these
things and so the people are pointing to
me pointing me to all these different
resources
now I'm not then taking all the
resources and staying up every night and
just going through all the information
and sort of reading everything that
everyone is sending to me deeply and I
have a few reasons for that the first is
is that with a few exceptions the
general arguments that people are kind
of pointing me to and the resources
whether I've looked at those things
specifically before or things very much
like them I kind of just want to and
this is a little bit of a defense of my
process which I said I didn't want to do
but I just feel like I have to say it
you know I didn't come to any of my
conclusions lightly right as I said
earlier I wasn't trying to get myself
out of the faith leaving the faith was
the scare
possible proposition for me right there
was so much there for me and it was a
very slow process over like 10 to 15
years and it was based on looking a lot
at a lot of these types of resources on
both sides I know I kind of listed out
some resources when I did my story and
people had a lot to say about what that
indicated those weren't that wasn't it
that wasn't the only thing I looked at
that was just a small sampling of some
things that I found compelling but I
don't remember everything that I looked
at but I didn't come to any of those
conclusions lightly so it isn't like Oh
have you been to this website because
they've got all the answers that you're
looking for it's like I probably have
seen those answers and processed those
answers and in the end after a layman's
investigation over the course of 15
years came to the conclusion that I just
didn't find those things compelling
right so that I'm not super like
chomping at the bit to get into him but
I want to talk a little more personally
about why I have a kind of an issue with
the whole enterprise of like apologetics
and these kinds of resources it seems to
me that one of the things that people
are doing is they're saying hey Rhett
here's a really smart person who knows a
whole lot more about this than you do
and they've got a really compelling book
about it check it out so there's a
tendency as I talked about in my story
to find a smart person right find a
smart person who believes what you
believe and use that as justification
that it's cool and reasonable to believe
what you believe and so you kind of get
into this appealing to smart people game
and I don't know how to say this I'm not
I'm trying to be as charitable as
possible but I don't think that this is
a really fruitful game for certain kinds
of Christians to play because when you
get depending on the subject once you
get into the hey here's a smart person
who believes what I believe game
you're gonna find pretty quickly that
you're gonna get outnumbered by the
smart people on the other side of that
issue that you're trying to get people
to see take evolution as an example
right the vast majority of biologists
the vast majority of people who have
given their lives to studying a you know
biology believe in common ancestry so
when you find a really smart scientist
who doesn't believe in it and be like
hey it's like well I can find a hundred
smart scientists who disagree with him
so playing that game kind of defeats
itself after a while does that make
sense yeah yeah but I see it done so
often and I also did it but I think that
there's very few issues that I talked
about in my journey whether you're
talking about archaeology or whether
you're talking about New Testament
scholarship where that wouldn't be the
case now interestingly the closer and
closer you get to Jesus you know when
you get into like New Testament
scholarship a lot of people who have
devoted their lives to the study of the
New Testament there's a lot you have to
be a certain kind of person to get to
that point in the first place so the
proportion of people who disagree about
that is a little bit different than say
evolutionary biology does that make
sense
definitely but you do have plenty of
people who got into it and dug into it
very deeply who came out on the other
side and said oh I got into this because
of my love for an interest in Jesus and
then when I started seeing the realities
I actually was very troubled and moved
away a lot of people say go to go to
seminary there's one of two options
either you're gonna become a deeper
believer you're gonna you know your
faith is gonna deepen or you're gonna
leave it it's not gonna stay the same
but when you talk about Christian
apologetics in general something I
thought about recently because I have
been you know watching a lot of these
podcasts and going III still I loved I'm
kind of gin you know genuinely
interested in this stuff so out of my
own interest I still read these articles
and look at these things to some degree
but one of the things that it's kind of
struck me about just the enterprise of
Christian apologetics is that the whole
idea is that you can use basically logic
and reason to make a defense of the
Christian faith to make it seem
reasonable and logical but it feels like
you know in take the take the the issue
of the resurrection which is kind of the
linchpin of the whole thing right so
there's plenty of people who have
written books and I've read them some of
them about why the basically the best
explanation of the events around Jesus
resurrection is that he actually bodily
raised from the dead explains in the
empty tomb and explains the start of the
early church yada yada yada right heard
the arguments but I find it interesting
that the best defense of the
Resurrection which is a miraculous
unbelievable unreasonable illogical
event is to use logic and reason to try
to make it seem like it actually
happened to me the resurrection is the
ultimate test of faith it is saying I'm
gonna believe something that is
unbelievable isn't that what makes it a
beautiful thing to believe from the
standpoint of faith but if it really
happened everything around you could
have logical historical philosophical
cultural convert analysis of it right
but I feel like all the historical
logical analysis of it from the
standpoint of someone who's trying to
argue the resurrection I think they're
very much overstating their case because
I don't I think that it's like again I
told you I knew somebody who wrote a
term paper explaining why the
resurrection happened and I feel like
they definitely there's some logical
leaps in there and there was their
justifying something that is okay it
could have happened the best you can get
to is it could have happened if you if
you believe that resurrection is
possible it is possible that Jesus
resurrected and you but what I'm saying
is that
to me it feels like you take the magic
and the beauty out of something and I'm
just using the resurrection as an
example but what I'm saying is that
post-enlightenment all this very super
reductionist thinking that people are
applying to the faith to God in his
action in the world and people's
relationship with him to me the
reductionism takes the faith and the
supernatural we're not talking about
reasonable things we're talking about
God this external personal force moving
into the physical world and doing things
that defy all logic and reason so when
you start trying to put your logic and
put God into the reasonable and logical
box you're kind of taking away some of
his attributes in my mind which leads me
to I personally think the most
intellectual intellectually defensible
Christian position is something called
biblical presupposition ilysm right
which is basically you just start with
the presupposition that the Bible is
true and that everything flows from that
now do I find that compelling no do I
subscribe to that no but it I can
understand it and I find that the people
who kind of start with this
presuppositionalist viewpoint have a lot
less trouble getting into this
tit-for-tat logic and reason argument
back and forth because it's just like I
don't have to deal with your arguments
because it's I just accepted as true I
just feel like the enterprise of
Christian apologetics for a lot of
people if you go into it with an open
mind and an open heart and you kind of
say I'm gonna follow where that wherever
the truth leads I think one of the
reasons that so many people like me when
they take on that particular they go
down that path they end up where I'm at
is because exactly what I said it's
because you're taking and you're
applying logic to it if you're gonna do
that you're going to end up in a logical
and reasonable place which I don't
believe is a place of faith does that
make sense yeah I don't I'm I'm not
gonna add anything to
okay well I didn't want to spend too
much time talk again I don't I like
talking about that stuff but I don't
want it I don't want it to be the our
podcast so let's talk about some more
personal things let's go back to as
personal as we possibly can
I mean to make this even more personal
I'm gonna say that this question came
from just say the night just a man named
Daniel a man named Daniel I almost said
Daniel no characters named Daniel he
likes to have fun
what are your takes on miracles such as
healing and unexpected blessings in
another question I don't know if this is
I think I just grabbed this from
somewhere else have you ever had a
supernatural experience and if so how
would such an experience fit into your
worldview tell okay have we ever had a
lots of people ask this question for
naturally how do you because a lot of
people said God moved in my life in an
undeniable supernatural way and
therefore regardless of what you're
going to say about you know the
foundation of the faith it's so real and
so personal and I've seen with my own
eyes or I've experienced something that
is undeniably supernatural and gods
movement in my life and therefore I'll
never depart from him how do you relate
to that um oh you were asking me well I
was I was I didn't really hear your
restating a question because I was
thinking of if if I've ever experienced
something miraculous I I don't I don't
remember ever experienced anything
miraculous I think in our particular
church it was like we weren't taught to
we weren't taught to expect miracles it
wasn't a part of the there weren't
healings associated with like our church
services that wasn't an that wasn't the
denomination we came from yeah we pursue
up to something you might call
dispensationalism which is the idea that
miraculous activity by the Holy Spirit
is coincides with the dispensation right
so a dispensation it like so when
obviously there's all kinds of miracles
in the
because a Jesus is doing them so you've
got God in the flesh they're doing
miracles and then you've got all these
early church miracles when the Holy
Spirit is basically coming on people at
Pentecost and then a few years after but
God doesn't do but God doesn't do that
anymore because he doesn't need to
that's kind of but that doesn't mean
that occasionally God's gonna answer a
prayer but it'll be one of those things
it's like did this person get better
from cancer because the church prayed or
was it just it just happened or was it
the medical team but it wasn't like
somebody's gonna come in and like grow
hair of a different color or their legs
are gonna get longer they're gonna stand
up from being you know disabled from for
ten years like that what didn't happen
in our church but I do understand that
it happens in many people's traditions
but based on that teaching I never
really looked for it I never expected it
I've been thinking like a corollary
question people have asked it's like
what about answered prayers you know if
you want to put that like in a near
miracle or like in the miracle category
I guess they're like miracle light like
this well it sounds like a spread
miracle whip but I when I was thinking
back my memories fuzzy but I my my
prayer life was was not that vibrant and
I don't recall ever asking God for
something that I didn't think he could
give me their won't to be unreasonable I
didn't want to be I didn't want to you
know I didn't want to ask for too much
you know that's but when you're taught
how to pray it's like you got adoration
you got confession you got Thanksgiving
and then if you haven't fallen asleep by
that point you got supplication acts and
I never got I just I had this feeling
that like I just never had I didn't I
didn't want to call God on the carpet I
don't know it's like I didn't want to be
proven wrong maybe that was part of it
deep down subconsciously I had a lot of
again I don't want to go back to the
guilt thing but like I knew that I
didn't really have a great prayer life
and I put that on me but I don't I don't
remember ever expecting miracles or
really expecting healing you know I
especially like after college in the
church that I was involved in there it
was a it was a it was a different strain
of Christianity and it you know they
started the in that church we believe
that like the people who were going to
be saved like had been chosen ahead of
time which means that others were chosen
actively for damnation ahead of time and
there's there's biblical passages that
are that that see well say a lot more
people believe that then you would think
but it was very and you know we we joked
and called ourselves the frozen Chosin
because it wasn't it wasn't a dynamic
experimental expectation it was pretty
heady that God was it was pretty heady
God wasn't gonna show up and do
something crazy because he didn't need
to
he had already he'd been there and done
that need to believe it or don't right
you know but don't don't demand it who
are you to demand that God do something
so like this was the this was the
environment that I operated in and I
don't really recall experiencing a
miracle one of my mom's friends who was
like she was she was one of those what I
felt like more the spiritual like in in
touch with things that she that are
ineffable and she was also a Christian
she said I had this premonition it was
kind of like a dream but it was more of
a vision that your son she was talking
to my mom link was in front of this huge
crowd in a stadium and he was it was
like he was Billy Graham and he was like
preaching the gospel and I was in high
school when she told me this my mom
relayed it and I was like okay thanks
for that pressure I don't know maybe she
saw us performing in a venue and she
didn't realize that we were just singing
a dumb song so I was there you were not
there okay well it sounds like a solo
act to me yeah to be honest with you
that hasn't happened I mean that that's
a vision
a miracle but well I I have what I would
have called my miracles I'm gonna tell
my stories okay right now all right and
then I'm gonna tell you my perspective
on them first miracle 1998 I'm in New
York City working with Campus Crusade
for Christ summer in the city is what we
called it where me and I don't know 30
40 other college students worked with
the churches in the inner city to do
basically you were with a different
church every single week and doing
whatever outreach and stuff they were
organizing and interestingly one of the
things that I was struggling with at the
time this is one of them I first sort of
I don't remember exactly where I learned
it but when I started learning more
about how the New Testament came
together mm-hmm
specifically you know the way the Canon
was decided and the counsels of these
church fathers getting together quite
some time after the the writing of the
Bible to then kind of determine what the
books of the Bible would be like exclude
something about that book at Thomas
exclude some of those those books and
this was Mastretta might for someone who
had never really thought about this and
was just like oh the Bible is God's Word
so you kind of just imagined that it was
it was somebody just you know like I
know I think the the tradition of the
Quran is that God basically filled
Muhammad and then he wrote it I I'm I'm
ignorant about that but I think it has a
little bit in like the tradition of the
Book of Mormon I think is that God
filled the Holy Spirit kind of came upon
Joseph Smith and got him to write it
like that kind of feels like a good
thing to kind of fall back on like it
feels a little tighter you know from a
scripture standpoint versus like well
some people wrote some books we don't
know exactly what
their intentions were and then but you
get to the miracle you were doubting
right so I started thinking about this
and had some doubts about it and I
specifically was arguing with a Muslim
student on some college campus in New
York at Cameron which one it was now
arguing but we're having a friendly
discussion where I was he started to
attack the New Testament in this way
basically saying what I was just talking
to you from a Muslim perspective and
basically saying how the Quran is more
superior because of this and I didn't
have any answers for him because I
hadn't really looked into it so and of
course I'm in New York
it's 1998 I don't really have access to
the internet because we didn't have
cellphones and there was no computer
anybody had so I didn't really have any
way to research or anything so this case
just kind of ate at me as I continued to
do ministry throughout the summer and
then one day we went square-dancing
because of course square dancing was
what every college students student who
knew which way was up was doing in the
late 90s especially in Christian groups
before we squared danced like rabbits I
just mix metaphors there because we
couldn't have sex we were square dancing
yes that's kind of what I was getting at
with the rabbits thing you couldn't
grind so you squared right and so we
went to the Lincoln Center or something
I can't remember if we were to square
dance and then we had to come back and
of course we're using the subway system
and there's no cell phone or anything so
you're like using your map that you've
got and we realized that the subway
station that we need to get on the
subway we need to get on to get to a
story which is where we were living had
closed because it was so late
but there was a stop across Central Park
that we could get on but it was only
gonna be open for like ten more minutes
so we all start running across Central
Park not the long way the short way it's
not that hard to do we've got just a
little bit of time to get to the subway
station we get there we go down we move
through the turnstile and then we get on
to the subway and I go to my seat and
right at the seat that I'm about to sit
down at it's a sheet of paper okay I
pick up the sheet of paper and it's just
like
a portion of a paper like a term paper
like so just high hex just types
intended out not a professional
publication and it basically begins to
explain why the New Testament is
necessary how you couldn't just stop
with the book of Malachi but that the
Old Testament was calling for the
fulfillment in the New Testament and I
took that sheet of paper and I said
thank you God for proving yourself to me
I'm not gonna doubt about this anymore
and put it in my journal you stole
somebody's paper Big Time miracle right
what is my perspective on that now I
told you the story the way that I've
told it many times the way I told it to
groups of people when I was a Christian
you know I'm gonna tell you the rest of
the story as Paul Harvey would say hmm
because the way I told the story Paul
Harvey wrote most of the New Testament
[Laughter]
the way that I would tell that story
is I told it in a kind of a sensational
way right I kind of set you up with what
I was doubting and then I went to this
particular seat that was in the
particular place that I went to and
there's a sheet of paper and it would
rest this thing directly yeah the
reality of the way that it happened
sounds like your biscuits one made a
better story that way but the reality of
the way that that's also the way that I
told myself by the way when I would go
back to that miracle
time after time but the way that it
actually happened everything leading up
to getting on the subways true and I was
doubting this stuff but we got on the
subway there was flyers like all over
the all over all multiple seats like it
wasn't just the seat that I was going to
it was everywhere okay when I got to it
and read it it was someone who is
mentally unstable had written a bunch of
sort of religiously informed gibberish
oh like a manifest and in this
and it wasn't just a sheet of paper it
was it was a few sheets of paper and as
I read it
nothing really made sense and it was
like this person seems a little bit off
but oh but there is a line in here that
says something about and just like the
book of Malachi is calling out for the
book of Matthew blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
so I found a sentence I was dealing with
something in my heart and it was sort of
tearing me apart in a lot of ways and
then I found something that was was
quite a coincidence was quite
serendipitous and was quite unusual and
I was able to make that connection so
and and it really put my doubts at ease
at the time now looking back on that do
I think that that was orchestrated by
God well if I did then I probably
wouldn't be where I am right now no I
don't I think it was a coincidence that
I'd then incorporated into my framework
and bolstered my belief with it my
second story much easier than that it
was actually that same was that the same
summer I was a camp counselor at a camp
at the tri-state area near New York yeah
and I had a bunch of inner-city kids who
were coming out to the wilderness to be
in this camp and these kids it come from
broken homes and they were just wild and
very difficult to contain and control
okay and I was in charge of them and one
night they were just going absolutely
ballistic in this cowled are they what
ages retime 13 okay probably like 7 or 8
of them they're going absolutely nuts
and being completely disrespectful but
also like almost fighting each other and
I'm like sitting there like I don't know
what to do so I go outside and they're
like super loud and like fighting I go
outside and I place my hand on the cabin
and pray for peace and then immediately
they get quiet Wow did you feel power
leave your hand
no now that's the way I used to tell the
story now I'm going to tell you the real
version of the story
the rest of the story is I never heard
that one by the way when are the other
one I went out you only told me the
first part which tells me like the fact
that you would even just by the way that
subway story you only told me the first
version you didn't even tell me like hey
man but there were a lot of pamphlets
and I think that it was like some weird
man fit you never ever told I haven't
come to grips with it until more
recently so it was but it became okay go
ahead but the rest of this story is that
I place my hand on the cabin and I
prayed and then a couple of minutes
later they got quiet
it wasn't like immediate if it had it
been it still could have been a
coincidence but it was you know did you
tell that one publicly yeah you did yeah
because and I didn't feel like I was
being dishonest it's just when I'm
really really honest about what happened
I'm like okay well I it's it you can
change the details a little bit and make
it a little bit more sensational no so
okay now I'm not speaking for everybody
this is me I have no doubt that people
listening right now there's somebody
other here's like well I got dude I got
specific miracles that cannot be
explained any other way here's the only
here's what I can say for myself it was
which is essentially what link said I've
never experienced anything unambiguously
supernatural in my life everything that
I've experienced I can find it isn't
difficult for me to find a reasonable
explanation for it but a lot of that has
to do with the fact that this the
tradition I came from which we didn't do
miracles and I had a couple of stories
when I was doing some stuff with Campus
Crusade that I can now see like well I
mean it could also be a coincidence so
it's not definitively it's not
unambiguously supernatural but the
second part of the question is what
would you do if you experienced a
miracle an unambiguous miracle now in
the year 2020 thinking the way that you
think for me if you go back about five
years yeah six years when I was kind of
making the decision to be like
I'm getting out of this now gonna think
this way anymore an unambiguous miracle
at that time would immediately brought
me right back to traditional Christian
faith the faith of my my my teenage
years whatever right but I got to be
honest with you if I experienced
something unambiguously supernatural now
I would just be like Oh supernatural
things happen they oh that is a that is
a feature of the universe's supernatural
things can't happen because I'm not
ruling that out but it doesn't logically
follow from me personally given that can
the conclusions I've come to up to this
point to then all a sudden undo all
those conclusions just because something
supernatural can happen to me the only
conclusion that I would come to is
supernatural things can't happen does
that make sense yeah well for me if some
if I would have experienced a miracle
while in the faith then I would have
picked it apart because that's what I
was always taught to do because of what
I already said I find it interesting
that both of those stories that you told
happened that summer when you were in
New York you were serving in churches
that were much more what we called
charismatic care I witnessed two
exorcisms you okay you didn't talk about
what those are miracles what do you mean
you witnessed two exorcisms well I
didn't believe that they were actually
exercised because of what we were taught
even even at the time I was like this
but you were in it okay so you didn't
believe those exorcisms but but man I
want to hear those stories nothing
special no voice changes no levitation
it was like run-of-the-mill somebody
just yelling really loudly and
everyone's saying that they were
possessed so I mean we're not talking
yeah did they calm down did something
leave their body yeah they calm down
they calm down okay I'll say they calmed
down that would be my best explanation
it was underwhelming to you yes it was
not believable but you were in a more
open place and you were open to looking
and claiming your own miraculous
experience because I try ask for
give the tongues that summer as well in
that environment like you would never
have asked for to speak in tongues
because we were taught that like again
that was a prior dispensation and it was
basically just learning other languages
but right but I but I did I did ask for
the gift of tongues it didn't happen did
not receive it and yeah I've always just
again it's the combination of what we
were taught and just how my brain works
I've always been I didn't feel like I
needed that to have my faith system was
intact without that so I actually I had
I I didn't need it
I didn't need to believe those I
actually feel like right now I hope that
I'm more open to miracles now I then I
because I never have been that's what I
I just want you know I want again this
is what I want and how much does that
matter when it comes to what's true none
um but it it maybe it does because if
you don't want something okay all right
now if you if you're not open to it
reach it brother maybe you can never see
the truth of it so I want to be open I
don't want to be shut off to to God's
activity in my life I want to cultivate
I'm a spirituality yeah I get that again
that's what that's what I've already
said but I just to use this the miracles
as an example I'm instinctively
skeptical but I want to be more open
yeah I'm on the I'm with you on that
that sounds good I like that yeah cuz
why not I don't want to I don't want to
miss out on that and unless it involves
hell and then I'm like I don't know
I don't think I do I'm not signing up
for this kit and kaboodle okay I think I
follow one of the things I will say is
that as a Christian and especially as a
Christian in a particular denomination
which it was nondenominational but it
was essentially like
formed Baptist or something like that
but we were really good at discounting
all kinds of miracles from other
traditions including the Catholic
tradition right the Catholic tradition
is kind of known for ongoing miracles
and they have like a whole group of
people who like verify miracles that
happen at certain locations and they're
kind of more into that and our
perspective on that was all bull
I mean to be quite honest is it was just
bull it was like it was wishful thinking
but it wasn't actually happening and it
was really like it was so so easy to not
to not consider Catholic miracles as a
Protestant it was so easy it was like
turning over in bed Oh easy didn't even
cross my mind
it was so easy so I just find it
interesting that like I never I've never
believed in ghosts I never really
believed in demons we have friends now
that like talk about seeing ghosts I'm
like well I just wanna I want to finish
my point
okay sorry because I don't want to
people to think that I'm talking crap
about Catholics in particular what I'm
doing is I'm just saying that you
talking crap about Catholics no I'm
saying that the perspective that I was
under at the time was that that wasn't
legitimate and so and I didn't care
about whether or not they were offended
right and so what I'm saying now is that
I believe that the miracles that people
again I don't know my yes is that the
miracles that people experience today in
the context of church or any religion
are probably not actually miracles that
that's that's my I could be wrong it
certainly doesn't help when you've got
you know the easiest targets of
televangelists rigging miracles yeah
every style every time until
definitively proved every time again go
down on on these guys who are everybody
feeling oh he's got an earpiece the
apologetic guy he's got an earpiece
but finisher point ghosts may exist man
I never believed in ghosts demons any
that we have close friends who like talk
about specific and ongoing encounters
and you know and it's like well you know
my former self would just be like just
almost you would would talk [ __ ] behind
your back
well you and I would write yeah I don't
do that anymore well I like the idea of
ghosts because it makes horror movies a
lot scarier and I like being scared and
the moment that you begin just
explaining it all away and saying that
this does it just can't happen then all
of a sudden Annabelle's room is not that
scary you know I'm saying that yeah I
just yeah and I'm not to that point yeah
so there could be something there I'm
just again I'm just trying to give my
perspective can I uh speaking of your
perspective I do want to get your
perspective on the on leaving me on the
side of the road because some people
it's like they only they were gay got
upset with you maybe I told the story
wrong but it to me
well I I'll let you speak but it was
like they were angry with you but I
guess it was maybe at that point in the
story yeah you came back I find it yeah
I found it really interesting that
people were upset with me once you hear
the whole story that's a that's an
interesting take I think it's just a
misunderstanding
but yeah anything at the time because
you were telling your story I don't want
it wasn't about my perspective so
there's a few logistical questions that
we did get like we were on Philip
defranco's podcast which should be out
by now we talked about a lot of this
stuff by the way and he asked us about a
lot of questions about how we're
processing the last year's so if you
want to listen to his podcast we got
into it over there and got into some
stuff that we haven't talked about here
and that we probably won't yeah I got I
got I got a little carried away a few
times yeah in a way that I try to
control myself a little bit more on you
focused yeah you felt like it wasn't
your show so you could write yeah
hee hee he asked us a clarifying point
that like yeah you you didn't drive all
the way home you drove over the hill you
drove over the horizon and apparently
parked somewhere where then you could
walk and dramatically come over the
horizon which you definitely did yeah
well just to give you my perspective on
this so I was I was upset with you for
drinking right because I knew and I were
in the band not because I was an [ __ ]
but because we had basically made like a
commitment to each other and to God that
we're not gonna do that we're not gonna
be kids who-who party that's not what we
do we Jesus is our party we were in the
wax paper dogs and we as a band had made
a commitment every time we got together
to rehearse which was at least once a
week it was like such an important we
would we would sit down in a circle and
we would pray with each other and we
would share struggles we were going
through we would encourage each other
and hold each other accountable to not
holding up the commitments that we had
made and asked our fellow band members
to hold us to so it was something that I
had put out there hey I want to be a
positive example we want to invite our
friends to these concerts we're gonna
we're gonna give people an opportunity
to like become a Christian and I don't
want to blow that by there being cracks
in my armor basically I we thought I
invited it we had to be different and we
had to have a tangible difference in our
life and one of those easy tangible
differences was we don't get drunk we
don't get drunk on wine we get drunk on
the Holy Spirit and so or what was it
vodka I don't know what you had that
night is some sort of liquor I did not
know we don't get drunk on some sort of
liquor I do not know we get drunk off
the Holy Spirit because of that witness
we called it once I said that I wanted
to get drunk they put on Merle Haggard
misery and gin yeah they knew they got
you and got Merle get you but that's a
good song because you did that I knew
that that's what I was that night let's
say it was Jim okay you had basically
compromised your witness and so if you
compromised the band's witness and
no as your friend who knew that you
didn't want to do that ultimately and
you felt bad about it I was like well
what am I gonna do I'm going to and
again as we explained on Phil's podcast
we were man we were so dramatic
sensational like everything was like we
was like we were ritual is being to like
Creed make everything that we were doing
cinematic and like we have this like a
ceremonial aspect to it the big rock and
the little rock that we had in the
conversations we had the blood oath was
a ceremony I we grew up in a church
where I mean it was it was new form
Baptist ceremony like it was like church
camp tike ceremony stuff but it was it
was meaningful and I think that I was
you think as part of that but I think
this is I I think this is also me and
just the way me and you have always been
yeah in a way we've conducted our frames
you name places like you know if you
find a tree you got it we'll call it the
tree with a capital T you know you you
you got to make the fabric of life be
even more exciting than it already is
I'm not cotton right mylar we were mylar
but I so here what I was thinking was is
like okay he shouldn't have done this
and I need to communicate two things I
need to communicate judgment and
forgiveness judgment and mercy and so
it's like to me the perfect and I was
kind of just pulling this out of my ass
as I was doing it but I was like all
right I'm gonna kick him out with the
car and drive over the hill because at
that point he'll be like damn my friend
just kick me out of the car yeah or
drinking I feel I think I have feel the
weight of my sin exactly and then I was
like but I'm not not an [ __ ] I'm
gonna park the car and walk back to him
in this like moment of cinema and peek
over the horizon and come and join you
and not say a word
and by coming back over the horizon and
meeting you I'm basically saying hey man
you screwed up but I love you I forgive
you now let's walk together let's get
back to the destination let's not do
that again that's what I was thinking
yeah and I you know I don't even though
I don't feel exactly the way that I felt
at that time I don't think the same way
that I think at that time like I regret
many things in life I don't regret any
of that I don't regret that right yeah
and you know I don't regret getting mad
at you for getting drunk when you were
16 years old I don't think that 16 year
old should get drunk not from a
moralistic standpoint but it's just like
hey it's probably not a great idea
yeah there's consequences to your
actions and it doesn't have to be that
the consequence is that God is then mad
at you you don't have to go there to
know that no no there's immediate
tangible consequences to that kind of
behavior you don't have to be a genius
to extrapolate and figure out what those
things are the risk of swallowing a
penny being one of those right you could
choke on a penny and die yeah so you
know what next time yeah next time you
do something stupid I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave you on the side of the road I'll
do it I'll do it tomorrow
you did plenty of stupid stuff but I
never got that dramatic with you man
yeah I didn't I didn't do that
particular thing I don't know at the
first drink I had the girls for you it
was well girl besides the wine that we
made for ourselves when we were like 15
which we couldn't I got drunk off that
that was a question we couldn't have got
drunk off that but we thought we could
and we were it was just so exciting we
had and that was really well be more
perfect yeah it was justifiable because
Jesus made water into wine that's not
how we justified it we were just like
although there are some Baptists who
think it was grape juice which still
makes me laugh to this day but um it was
the girls for you man I like the ladies
we we had to we had to have a lot of
conversations at a certain point I think
you just stopped telling me what you
were up to I mean you got to figure it
you got to figure things out you would
tell me and I would then the wheels will
start turning and I'd be like
I think if I'm not upset with him and
that might mean I can do it too
with my girlfriend not sex any warning
you're using that term loosely yeah I
didn't do it
just a little petting I don't recall it
heavy petting it was yeah I mean I
didn't I didn't do it but if it was I've
never heard the term heavy petting
outside of like a purity culture it's
weird like heavy petting it's like it's
just a weird phrase there's even no
heavy petting sign at a petting zoo
careful
I was not tented I did not need a sign
no heavy petting
I'm sure that's that's not a poster
somewhere okay I I mean do you get
through everything you want to pet
there's what there's one more there's
one more question that I feel like we
should answer even though I think that
we've probably sort of hinted at this
she's a lot of people have asked the
question well a guy named Cody asked
this question because I did write it
down just about just about the part of
your story again the question is just
about the part your story where you make
it a point several times to talk about
how real your relationship was with
Jesus just a later claim he isn't real
how could it be both a lot of people
have asked this question like I
understand he said that it was real it
seemed like he was as real as if he
physically manifested himself to you
again this answer is not going to be
satisfactory to anyone who believes that
they are actually in relationship with
God or in relationship with Jesus you're
gonna conclude that we just never had a
real relationship with Jesus if this is
the way that we would characterize it
and that yes you're right I can't really
I honestly can't argue with it but I
believe that we were a part of a
community that was committed to a
certain way of seeing the world and we
had lots of people in our lives who were
reinforcing that viewpoint and that was
kind of every
cool thing it was just we bought into a
philosophy right and part of that
religion part of that way of thinking
was that you basically you're in
relationship with God like you've got
the whole East Bay ceccolini ship with
Jesus but it's really the Holy Spirit
that's filling you and motivating you
and keeping you from doing things and
there were times when I would
specifically be singing praise and
worship music which was a big part of
the groups that we were in and I would
just feel completely overwhelmed and I
wasn't we didn't do the whole like
getting slain in the spirit never got
knocked down by anybody but had deeply
emotional reactions during like you know
different conferences in places where
you were just like on fire for God and
just and I actually had physical things
happen to me like I would feel like a
tingling kind of coming down from the
top of my head and like getting in my
ears and like there's there's like a
physical manifestation of what I thought
at the time was the Spirit filling me
interestingly like I can listen to
praise and worship music to this day and
kind of get myself back into that place
I can listen to easy lover by Phil
Collins and that other guy and get out
of that place but so I think a lot of
the things that I was I mean just the
tingling I was interpreting as evidences
of the Holy Spirit
we're just evidences of the way humans
work you know and they were deeply
emotional and and but there was I mean
and I know this is true of you too but
like I was journaling my prayers because
I had a hard time actually like focusing
on praying but there was a lot of
praying it was a it was kind of a
one-sided conversation but when you
start to but it I I could sense
responses oh you're like you you read
the you know they taught you - we were
taught to read the Bible and study the
Bible in a way that like the Holy Spirit
would bring things out of it like you
would gain insight and relating it to
who you were and I you would we would
seek guidance on every single major
decision
and it's certain stints of my life every
single minor decision yeah and you
really get a sense that you were that we
I was guided to make decisions by God I
mean we even we went through workbooks
called experiencing God how to determine
God's will for your life all of the you
know it's like we were trained the the
the practices in order to connect with
God and to be guided by God and but for
me making decisions was a huge thing
like my journal was filled with
everything that I talked about and then
the second thing that was filled with
was me trying to assess if I if if I
could marry Christy if she was the one
for me like I obsessed about this and I
felt like um on one hand I became
convinced that like okay God is blessing
this decision this is a wise decision
this is the right decision on the other
hand I feel like I'm I missed out on a
lot of like experience and like falling
in love with my wife because I wanted it
to be such a I wanted it to be something
where God granted me permission and give
me a sign or give me the specifics and I
felt like I got that those are all
aspects of my active relationship with
God you're the one who made the
statement I didn't make the statement
but it's true of me too I believe that I
did have a real back-and-forth
conversational relationship with God I
just thought that I wasn't good at it
and that all the stuff I was trained to
do I just wasn't motivated enough and I
just it wasn't it was my shortcomings
not God's that that made me feel distant
yeah well you know when you're on staff
with Campus Crusade you have you're
encouraged to do something called a day
with the Lord every month right
Wow and this is essentially a day-long
devotional you might have you what we
call that your quiet
I am your devotion time every single
morning where you get up and you pray
and you read the Bible which I was okay
yet there were some good runs in there
right sir pretty much a struggle for
most Christians but I always loved the
day with the Lord you know it yeah oh
yeah I I loved it and what I would do is
I would take my Bible in my journal and
I would go to some spot in nature and I
would just sit there and I would just
pray and basically the funny thing is is
I still do this pretty regularly I just
don't call it a day with the Lord I just
go out into a spot in nature I don't
have the Bible I've got my journal I
might have a book or something that I'm
reading at the time but it just I just
sort through things right
and it's just like now I not talk out
loud to myself whereas I used to just
talk out loud to God but tangibly
practically the experience is no
different
I'm not trying to yeah I made lemon my
sound like sad or crass or whatever but
I'm just saying that not trying to be
dismissive I'm just saying when I think
back on what I was interpreting as a
two-way relationship where the Lord was
again I don't know the nature of the
universe and maybe that I was tapping
into some sort of spiritual plane that
exists that I don't fully grasp and
understand and I'm still open to that I
hope so yeah but I tend to think that
what was happening especially especially
during those times is I was just getting
away I was extracting myself from my my
day-to-day life and all the distractions
there and I was just getting some time
to just be still you know be still and
be in a meditative state and kind of
just things come to the surface and you
kind of work through things it's like if
you go to a regret to the gravesite of
someone that you love and you talk to
them and some people carry on that kind
of relationship for a very very long
time that person never speaks back to
them but there are tangible experiences
and they're seconds they they remember
what they look like and they remember
that you know in the same way that your
memories of a loved one are sort of the
it's the raw material by which you have
an ongoing conversation with them after
they die I kind of feel like the Bible
and church tradition and what you're
being taught is the raw material for
carrying on a relationship with Jesus
that might just be a conversation with
yourself that's my best guess as to
what's happening there as I always like
to say I could be wrong you probably are
right I'm sure I am in some way yeah
hashtag ear biscuits at this point are
we going to talk about this anymore
directly I don't know I don't
I predict not but again as we've said
before I think that these things will
percolate through in as we continue to
reminisce and air every single ear
biscuit or every couple I mean we're
always pulling from our past and now
we're able to talk about it in a way
that we haven't been able to yeah
certain aspects I gotta say it's so
we'll come up it's it's been really
really liberating personally I am I
think about just being able to talk
about it on Phil's podcast and you know
there was a lot of shame and also just
fear around just being honest about our
pasts and you know be able to just be
like this is this is who we were this is
who we are
yeah I don't know it's just it's a
healthier way to live you know yeah I've
experienced a lot of a lot of peace and
we can move forward that's so important
I feel like in and I'm glad that in this
venue you can come along for the ride
that's what's gonna happen I do have a
wreck I have a wreck and a fence with it
I wanted to do this last week but it was
your wreck so it's a little bit late but
I just wanted to shout out dear Hank and
John which is Hank and John Green's
podcasts good friends of ours and John
shouted us out and I'm not just doing
this to return the favor and that's part
this but John has been listening to the
podcast
I'm not saying Hank has it but John
specifically said that he had been
listening to the our stories and our
deconstruction and you know just the way
that he described it on their podcast
was just meant a lot to to us and
they're also they're just super
thoughtful guys who you know basically
as close to us as you can be in terms of
well we're two guys that have known each
other for most of their lives
probably theirs or like all their lives
who do a business like this and are just
trying to be husbands and fathers and
live life and figure it out and they're
just incredibly smart thoughtful funny
guys you have a very smart thoughtful
funny podcast but it but they've got
this thing where you can only listen to
it after you've listened to your
biscuits that's how their podcast works
right yes I don't even try yep
don't listen to it before you've
listened to it until you're fully caught
up with us but then go on over there and
they'll walk in with open arms all right
we'll speak at you next week love you
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]